οτεκίνου άρκεταλοκάοκόυλάτια πολογούμε για δελέξεις που θρύσουμε προς τον κόσμο και για τό το κεφάλιο
μπορά κάου σθα σουπό πολλά πράγματ άλλα εμπυρωρισμένα τα λεσοκάτι τελευταίο αν το δι σήμερα
στο δρόμο να τμιλήσει το δησφιλεγωνα σουποκατί εγώ δεν κρατο κακίασε κανένα σε κανένα ταξι
αλλά το μόνο πράγμα που θέλογο να μουνα έρχετε μου πείσει γνώμη κανε αλάθα ρέγουν
πάρε μας ζήσουν συγνώμη θεώρις α το φιτό το φιλό όχομα καπνά ή ενώεφφορτόσας να
ξ ο χειος τες πλάε κάν ου και άλλα πράγματά το πία τώρα δν δεν
της ώρας στο φορόμου ευχαριστό παράπολύ που ίσους σήμερα μάζη μας εν τον η προσωπικό
ήτα ν τον ησυζήτηση ονα κόψεις ότι δήποτα πό τούτα που είπαμε θα έχουμε θέμα
σου το λέω τίν κόψε δεν ήξερω να μου κόψεις πράγματα που ποφέα κόψε μοαφέρεσης
ονόματα κια θσυν αντιβότα νέρας αρέντερα ίγου πάνω χαριστώ πολί γιατί θα σεξήτησεη και να
πα ξεχνάι ο κόσμος περίμεμε ότιτον το πράγμα αμε εξεπούλησε μπαντού πι χι γ εξακόσα
εβλί που το θαπλι και πιαγίνηκαν καπνός ελίψαση τα μηνήματα που μου στέλλουν ανθρώπηκαθμερινά που
τω το βιβλίο που άλλα ξεάλα ξεένει ζωή μο έχά α π τον τα κιλάέκοψα
τα ν αρκωτικά στα μέα τόιγάρο και πάει λευγιωπάε λέγοντας το συνιστώ σε όλους να
το πιάσουν να το διαβάσουν και νααεφαρμώσουν τα πράγματα πογράφει μέσα θα ξυπνήσουν έαν προ
και θα ενα λλη άνθρωποι κατομυρούχι αριστώόλη χρι στοφοεγαλά φιλές και φίλει άλλο ανταν λλά
εκασεφτασε στο τέλος του να ευχαριστήσουμε και σήμερα τον χωρικό μας τον πιν πάρο ήταν
μαζί του και μας κάεισε παρέα με τα ροφήματα του θα τα πούμε στο επόμενο
όκση να στε καλά καλή συνέχει